here and we have been running all over
downtown Seattle in search of brand new
games for you Peter's got one to talk to
you about in just a moment a little a
little fan service for people who love
old-school RPG actually well it's from
an old school developer but it's a new
game and an old-school series but we'll
get to that you saw game four from
behemoth right yes I saw the brand new
game from the behemoth you know the guys
who did castle crashers and battleblock
theater humor has always been a big part
of those guys games but in this one it
seems like the humor is like notched up
about 11 more points because whereas
those games were very like kind of
twitch faced reflex a platformer action
games this is a tactical action RPG hex
based movement system turn-based you got
to take your time it's very kind of
methodical but the humor is absolutely
batshit insane let me let me paint you a
picture a giant celestial bear monster
is floating through space and collides
into earth which causes the very fabric
of space and time to unravel and you
play just a humble blueberry farmer
named Horatio who is just trying to
survive amidst the chaos that happens
when the green bear blood acid is
raining down from the heavens and
causing everybody to turn into absolute
[ __ ] all right I'm with you I got it
and and from there you can imagine that
it probably gets a little bit insane
it's totally ridiculous but the sense of
humor oh my god I was just cracking up
constantly during the demo it looks
really good you were telling me that
there is a narrator that sort of you
know is describing what you're doing and
he picks on you half the time and you
are like as the player character
reacting to him yeah so the player coat
like the narrator is kind of a jerk and
he's picking on you and he's teasing you
constantly kind of strikes you as an
unreliable narrator maybe he's reliable
maybe he's telling the truth but he's
just a jerk bag but it's it's the same
guy from battleblock theater so like
totally insane but it looks really
really cool nice well you know I'm going
to take this mic and I'm going to talk
about Final Fantasy type-0 which is not
a game that's
can't I can't let go of the mic I need a
little give me that microphone all right
not a game that's very funny at all it's
actually a very serious game especially
for Final Fantasy this game came out on
the PSP in Japan three years ago we were
going to get it out in the West didn't
happen because apparently the PSP was
flagging Square Enix was not too happy
about that I will not have you speak ill
of the PSP in my presence around
patience patience so at e3 last year
squirt UNIX silently slip this
announcement that type 0 is coming to
playstation 4 xbox one and i got a
chance to see the game they didn't let
me play it and so this game it's sort of
like a Harry Potter esque setup you play
you go let's unpack that what do you
mean by that I'm getting there I'm
getting so you control a cast of 14
characters that are students at a school
for magic basically but it takes a
really dark turn so you are in this one
nation of many nations and all of a
sudden everyone kind of descends upon
your nation and you're at war and it's
like hey I know you guys are just
figuring this out but you got to defend
the whole country so good luck have fun
yeah and you know the game is a it's a
real-time action RPG and you swap
between all these characters at once to
do stuff and it looks really great like
for a PSP game being operas for HD I
wasn't expecting it to look that good
but it turns out they're using models
from the cutscenes of the game and using
those in real time okay and then
applying all sorts of great like
lighting techniques and things like that
they're still not talking release date
right now it's just ps4 and xbox one but
they were playing it on a pc it's made
with directx 11 so then maybe it'll come
out but they're not talking about it yet
hopefully never know like gameplay wise
what makes it different from us like a
final fantasy tactics or that type of
game well tactics obviously is like the
strategy final fantasy where you're on a
grid taking turns I mean this this is
not turn base like that or any other
final fantasy it's all real time so it's
actually kind of like maybe closer to
like realm reborn like the online final
fantasy we're final fantasy 12 you know
you're running around the map you see
you bunch of enemies and you smell
between characters to cast magic on them
but uh you know it honestly it's after
13 which was kind of a
I don't know kind of boring I'm really
looking forward to something different
and that's where we're getting from type
zero well any other little surprises
that you've seen around the show floor
so far something I can't talk about just
yet but yeah definitely stay tuned
gamespot I've been speaking to a lot of
Japanese developers a lot of really cool
things including some things that were
announced last year at PAX so stay tuned
for that stay tuned like how soon is is
happening am I going to go to gamespot
this afternoon tomorrow night okay
tomorrow night